how are you CD I'm doing well and
congratulations on a great week to you
guys nice brother I heard what you said
about Minneapolis rich I got to the
airport at about 420 this morning for my
flight because you know you want to make
sure you're there early they did warn us
right still could not believe the amount
of good cheer and a number of people
running around that Airport willing to
assist get people to the right places
I saw volunteers helping people at the
Delta counter not the counter but the
Delta kiosks and this is how you do it
and they weren't wearing Delta uniforms
the Minnesota people they did a
fantastic job they did they did in that
Stadium his first class world class so
what did you think was the number one
story of last night's Super Bowl
Charleston
well the track meet that broke out in
that game and Butler became a big part
of it because you have to wonder does he
help at all does he make some of those
plays or make it a tougher throw or
whatever you know the throw that that
that Foles made to Alshon Jeffrey for
the touchdown over Erik roe
well done bye-bye Jeffrey he had that
subtle little push to create the space
at the end he put it up there and gave
him a chance Rowe was out there for if
indeed those reasons are accurate
because he was a bigger body and still
made plays if you're gonna play a guy 97
98 percent of the snaps on defense all
year long I would think that they've
played bigger receivers before so I
think just as you said it defies Bellino
belief that that's really what was going
on word will leak out and we will find
out what really went down or at least a
pretty close approximation and he could
have helped make a difference in the
game but to say that he was the
difference in the game I think would be
taking it too far we don't know that he
would have would have or would not have
made some of those plays that would that
were not made but I think he would have
given them a better opportunity Charles
Davis joining us here in a Honda inside
a report the day after Super Bowl 52 so
what would you say was the biggest
difference maker in the game sure the
nick foles that nick foles
and Doug Peterson did not allow any of
that stage to be a real issue
wanted to look going into the game it
was it had to be a storyline I don't
care what we say you know I don't care
if you write a kid's fiction book if
you've got a coach who has that many
playoff games experience that many Super
Bowls against the coaches there for the
first time
it's a storyline and I think that the
Doug Peterson did something in this game
that coaches talk about doing but rarely
follow through on and it was what we saw
being aggressive you know transmitting
that to your team being true to who
you've been all year long calling those
plays on your sheet when the situation
arises that you have said okay if we get
in this situation this is the perfect
play for it and you and I both know rich
how many times coaches have talked out
for each of that and then you get into a
game like that and look up at the
scoreboard Rupp 10 ha let's not screw it
up all right give me the Sprint draw
right and duck and Doug Peterson what
look the Philly special came after a
timeout on fourth down where he had
plenty of opportunity to say forget it
kick the field goal right I thought
that's why he called the timeout Charles
I'll be honest with you talk to talk
about it you know and you know
everyone's in their ear you know there's
a lot of talk about these things and I
know I've listed I've been in these
rooms before and I know from talking
with different people
Amy traps from that great book okay
about about you know her experiences in
the NFL and she talked about her husband
talk about the John Maynard Keynes quote
which paraphrase says we live our lives
based essentially on what will give us
the least amount of blowback right or
what's the most defensible for us and
Doug Peterson did not call his game like
that every time he caught had a
situation to call for one thing it felt
like he was calling the other and was
hitting JJ on third and four he runs the
football you know I mean things of that
nature
the Phillies special after the timeout
yep we're gonna run it and it was
successful it was that kind of a night
for him he really assumed the stage and
never once backed off from it it really
was incredible and and and and for so
many people who said he can't obviously
would make
Foles his journey I went over it before
with him and you know Michigan State to
Arizona to being drafted to Chip Kelly
and him having that opportunity and then
falling out of grace they're being
traded for Bradford st. Louis was a
disaster now he has a shot that nobody
expected him to have because how great
whence was playing whence was on his way
to being the MVP of the league and then
all of a sudden one play and in Los
Angeles changes the entire storyline all
that said Charles Davis now that we are
in fact entering the talent evaluation
portion new knowing what is in the
hopper potentially drafting in
quarterbacks and also knowing Kirk
Cousins is going to be out there would
you if you are tuned quarterback needy
team in the National Football League
draft somebody or call Howie Roseman and
say what do you want for Falls would you
do that I'd call I would call first to
see what you want for foals because
experience in the league rich is
invaluable as you know and it's not just
off of a one blush shot that we're
seeing Falls right we you mentioned it
already he did win ten games one year as
a starter he went to a Pro Bowl albeit a
quote-unquote different system but how
impressive was it to watch Philadelphia
incorporate what he does best and did
not care that it looked a lot like what
Chip Kelly ran you know what I mean a
lot of coaches have too much ego for
that
who knew that's what the old guy did
we're not doing that I actually talked
with a Philadelphia coach before the
game on Sunday Rich and he told me I
said what did you do how did it go he
said listen we just said okay let's put
together our 20 best concepts and if we
have to dumb it down from there we will
and how many ways can we dress those up
and get you comfortable and let's roll
and that's what they did so whoever's
going to take Nick Foles on you got to
make sure you're willing to do those
things I would tick the tires on him
first but I also would be caution
everyone not to put a savior tag on it
mmm you saw what happened in this
situation and you mentioned what a
disaster the Rams were now a part of
that is what they were saddling him with
an offense remember Wood Wood had todd
todd gurley call the high school
yeah high school he had middle scoffing
so tag that but be careful about Savior
on the whole thing because that team
that he played with this year well Howie
Roseman did and surrounded him with even
with the injuries as a talented group of
people don't just think that that
translate so he goes to Cleveland
automatically they just start moving
it's tougher to do that way well you
know about though Charles I mean if it's
a Arizona does of what we're what we're
positing flips somebody for foals
for and or a or a draft pick Jets I mean
they're gonna say okay this is the guy
that lit it up beat Brady why wouldn't
you do that if you're the Jets you got
to beat Brady as long as he's still
there you know and you surround them
with the right people the question is is
the guy is the guy that we saw over the
last three weeks and Nick Foles that
could be a week in week out in the same
way that Rodgers and Brees and the elite
quarterbacks to this league row that's
the question that is the question and
let's go let's go and trace it very
quickly Ritter because the year they won
ten and got to the playoffs and I
believe New Orleans beetle that year at
home in the divisional round about
division
I think wildcard round so so they got
beat there but still a great year twenty
seven to the whole deal the next year if
I'm not mistaken they were six and one
six and two his quarterback rating had
dropped a little bit he's a little bit
over eighty four eighty eighty on
quarterback rating but there were six
and one six and two and he gets hurt and
things were never the same obviously
things went south with chip the whole
deal then they flipped him as you
mentioned to st. Louis well that wasn't
going to work very well although I did a
game of his where they beat Arizona in
Arizona when Arizona was still one of
those Super Bowl contending teams you
remember that little stretch they had
where they were hey Arizona and I saw
him win those games and make throws like
we saw during this playoff run but the
other side of it is when he did take
over from whence and getting his feet
wet remember going into the playoffs the
last fifteen third downs they were over
15 going into the playoffs they were the
underdog at home to Atlanta chiefly
because he was quarterback in that team
and people still didn't buy it the
second go-round
and he showed everybody a different side
in the
layoffs as opposed to regular season
down the stretch where it was a struggle
for them so yeah take him on but also
make sure you're surrounding him and
make sure you're willing to adapt to
what he does best and I think I think
you guys have already seen too that that
picture of Michigan State with those
quarterbacks right I'm amazing isn't it
him cousin boy we're all sitting here in
the same roster and when I watched of
the when I looked at the picture I was
looking at the other guys wondering
where are those guys today and what
tails would they have to tell us about
watching those three they're together
that ultimately became NFL players yeah
and one of them is now a Super Bowl MVP
Charles thanks to the call glad you made
it home safely we'll chat soon
yeah you guys get home safely as well
take care now
you got that Charles Davis at CFD 22 on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience